was the what was going on in San Diego
when that guy got bitten half by a shark
a couple years back they were training
for something yeah that's a funny you
remember that that was May of 2008 I
remember that like it was yesterday
so at the time I lived in San Francisco
and this is actually just before I swam
the Maui thing now that I think about it
that was 10 years ago I swam the Maui
thing in June of oh six at June of oh
eight so I'm doing all my training in a
swimming pool up in San Francisco
because I don't want to acclimate to
very cold water I actually want to be in
warm water but I needed one long ocean
swim of like 14 or 15 miles as my like
last training swim so I came down to San
Diego to do it and just by bad luck I
came down a few days after that guy was
killed now this was a guy I didn't know
him but he was a triathlete training
with a triathlon group that they would
go out and swim every morning and I know
the beach exactly where it happened in
Solana Beach and unfortunately like most
people who get attacked by great whites
they have a very they always attack the
same way which is below and behind
stealth bite up and and then they they
retreat so they're trying to basically
injure the prey so their prey
exsanguinate sand then they take off and
then they wait till you bleed out so
they never saw the shark but you could
tell from the bite marks it was I
actually had a friend who was on the
beach and saw him when he came out and
he was basically dead when he got to
shore he had he had bled to death the
problem is so in this case the shark had
bit him and cut through his femoral
arteries and veins and the saltwater
prevents you from having any hemostasis
so it exacerbates the blood loss so
that's generally how folks perish when
they're had a great what I'm out of the
water you know a bunch of other swimmers
came to his rescue and luckily that
commotion prevents the sharks from
wanting to come back so three days later
I go out and I'm swimming at that Beach
because I swim from my training swim was
La Jolla up to Solana Beach and back and
I got to tell you like three days after
a guy dies where you're swimming it is
it was about one of the most mentally
challenging
training swims to be like because you
can't see like the water at that part of
the beach is so murky you know and
you're only a couple hundred yards
offshore that like you can barely see
your hands when you're swimming and so
you're just thinking is this the day I'm
not interested in that gee I can't see
why yeah there's just something about
sharks - I mean they're to me one of the
most terrifying things but first of all
we're so inept in the water I mean even
a person like you is a great swimmer
yeah we're joke yeah what we are in
comparison to what they are it's just
you're you're throwing yourself into the
world of a super predator and to know
that one just jacked a person just a few
days before and you're out there
swimming around yeah although I will say
this you know when it's all said and
done all of the close encounters I've
had probably the scariest moment I've
ever had in the water was doing a swim
from Santa Rosa to Santa Barbara so
Santa Rosa Island which is the second
for this North Channel Island you got
San Miguel Santa Rosa Santa Cruz and
Anacapa represent the top four Channel
Islands so we did this November swim it
was a nighttime thing against women from
Santa Rosa Island to Santa Barbara and
at about 5:00 in the morning maybe 6:00
in the morning you're just starting to
get enough light where you can see and
you're out there so you really have
amazing visibility and I look down
probably 40 feet and I see this enormous
thing swimming like this which is how
sharks swim and I see the dorsal fin in
the position that freaks me out and the
tails this way but all of that is shark
right and I like you know like lift up
out of the water kind of hyperventilate
for a second and I'm thinking to myself
alright you got to make a judgment call
here if that's really a great white you
probably ought to get out of the water
but if you the moment you are out of the
water that's it the swim is over like
you just spend like months doing this
like it's run so then I convinced myself
and I think I'm right I think it was a
dolphin on its side because a dolphin on
its side would its fin would get tail
fin would be the same way and
could swim that way so and then I just
kept swimming but I mean that scared the
[ __ ] out of me well they have seen quite
a few of them off the coast of Malibu
there's other tons there's no question
that like they're there they are way
more plentiful than we realize
and all you do is talk to the fishermen
like the fishermen will tell you they're
like you look off Coronado I mean it's
like there's non-stop great whites
really oh yeah why are you freaking me
out Peter the good news is they see us
all the time and most the time they
realize we're not what they want yeah
they want seals yeah whenever they
attack us they're making a mistake
now is there a like a suit you can wear
like Kevlar suit to protect protects you
from getting bitten in half no but this
is so funny you bring this up I became
obsessed with this thing called the Oh
what was it called Christ you you put
the thing on your ankle like you had
like a little velcro thing you'd wrap it
on your ankle um had a tail like this
long you know like four foot long thing
and it was charged and it sends out an
electrical impulse that disturbs the
[ __ ] out of the Sharks the Sharks nose
is an organ that senses electricity so
when a shark like that it could be pitch
black it could be soot water and they
can still scope you you know from
hundreds of yards away based on the
electrical activity of your heart and
that organ is their nose so this little
thing I forgot what it was called like
the shark taser or some [ __ ] it puts out
a signal that like tases them and they
don't want to get within like oh there
it is chainsaw here the world's first
shark deterrent bands called the shark
bands worn on the wrist or ankle I don't
know I thought it had a different name
but because the one that I was gonna get
and did a ton of research into had a
really long tail hanging off it and that
became the problem he's his patented
magnetic technology to repel sharks so
the tail was a problem because of the
drag no because it would it sounds silly
but it would come up and zap you in the
nuts it's like so it became unbearable
to practice swimming in this thing here
every 37 seconds you'd get zapped by the
tail and I was just like as I like how
it says reduce the risk oh yeah hey can
I get some numbers please did you see
reduce by how much by one seven or
statistically and then it also is a
leash for your surfboard too you can use
one of those to trap it to your strap it
to your ankle yeah no it's gonna come to
me like in an hour I'll remember what
this silly thing was Jamie I'll probably
find it off of Catalina I know it's one
of the best shark fishing places in the
world I have a friend of mine who told
me that if you think about like wild
places on earth that are just overrun
with predators and terrifying like
predator prey activity Catalina Island
is one of the top spots in the world I
was like what are you talking about
he's like I'm telling you man the shark
fishing off Catalina Island is [ __ ]
insane and then I watched a television
show just you know synchronicity a
couple days later and it was these guys
shark fishing off of Catalina I was like
what in the [ __ ] I could have never
guessed they're catching Makos mostly
yeah and and it's actually my
recollection because we swam around
Catalina once as well the backside is
way more aggressive than the front side
the side that faces the Pacific side
they'd rather that's right yeah there's
way more easy stuff yeah I think that's
exactly where they were yeah it looked
pretty nuts I mean they were bringing in
these 15-foot sharks I was like what and
the [ __ ] these are just floating around
out there